which will prod he's got my dad he have
them in gorilla City so the name of
episode 13 is attacking gorilla City
what the hell is a gorilla City okay so
there are sentient highly intelligent of
all tequilas in earth too and they all
live in a city deep in the heart of
Africa her father Gary Wells went to
carillo city and is missing in action so
she's hoping that the team can come and
with her and help save her father you
mean by voluntarily going to the city of
super 8 barry and caitlin and cisco and
Julian's onerous to welcome to the
jungle baby while they're going through
the forest the trap rod appears and
captures them so now they're stuck in
these gorilla City cells unable to
escape grodd's dampening their powers yo
fly rod it will be sent to the arena and
executed and so we get to do a flash
gladiator fight in an arena full of
screaming gorilla where are you going
are you going to particle you know it's
just a city of them it might be the
greatest thing I've ever seen on
television easter is super gorilla best
worst video game ever
you
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie we got to
talk all about Grodd we got some new
footage let's break it down that is some
introduction it may be the greatest
thing that I've ever seen on television
before flash vs gorillas in an arena
gladiator style are you not entertained
everybody's going to be screaming that
during the episode so if you're new to
the channel I do flash videos every week
be sure to subscribe to get everything
and there is a flash ring giveaway going
on then I'll explain at the end of the
video but just address this footage so
you see Jesse quick explaining to them I
love how Joe is always the explainer
character he's the guy who always pipes
up when they have really complicated
science and says hey I don't I don't get
what you're talking about could you
please explain that to me cuz you dumb
it down a shade the only reason they do
stuff like that it's an old TV trick
it's just for people watching the TV
show that have absolutely no idea who
Grodd is because there's like this
hardcore fanbase that knows exactly
what's up the thing you have all these
other people the tune integer just like
I have no idea what's going on but
that's kind of what my youtube channel
is for so the only bad thing about this
is that we don't see so levar but they
did show off a picture of him last week
looks like it's from later in the
episode or maybe it was a CG test
because there's not a lot around here
but when they showed the big wide pan
shot from last year like when Grodd is
singing for the first time that looks
like the arena way down there but I do
love the explainer that he's dampening
their powers he knows how to do that
that's how smart he is and he's speaking
through Harrison wells just like he did
through general Eiling the voice actor
that does Grodd actually goes to a lot
of conventions you might be able to get
him to record a phone message for you
like get Grodd as your answering machine
message but I voted on a couple videos
about the premise of the episode so I'm
going to do like a top 10 things you
need to know about Gorilla Grodd he has
a really cool back story that's been
changed a couple times and there's a lot
of green lantern Easter eggs but number
10 the Big Green Lantern easter egg he
got his powers his mental abilities from
the same meteorite that gave Hector
Hamid his powers from the Green Lantern
comics they wreck on that later but that
was originally flash number 106 in 1959
so it goes way back they also changed
number 9 his origin story he was
supposed to be from a different earth
then later they changed that to make him
the disciple of this alien visitor
so it's really trippy when you started
out in the comics but this alien ship
crashes and that gives them our
intelligence so levar also becomes as
rival gaining intelligence in the same
way so they kind of become this
dichotomy that will see play out during
the episode but a number eight the alien
visitor also compelled them to create
gorilla City think of it as being on par
with Wakanda compared to other African
nations so much more advanced more
beautiful more in tune with nature
something you'd expect from a group of
guerrillas that are smarter than Jesse
quick who's probably the smartest person
on the show right now number seven he
has all kinds of powers you've seen most
of them on the TV show already telepathy
mind control psychic blast but he's also
as a result of his mutation is much
bigger than the normal gorilla which is
part of what makes him stronger than a
normal gorilla gorillas are very big on
their own they're already really
dangerous but you have to imagine he's
like the Schwarzenegger of gorillas 6 he
actually became the Flash's enemy on
accident he was actually going after so
levar who'd been captured by humans so
Grodd wanted so lavars powers of mind
control for himself so that he could
take over a gorilla City in when the
flash heard so lavarse distress call he
came to help in fought off Grodd
starting their beautiful relationship as
the worst of enemies number 5 he's
actually gone back in time to try and
wipe humans out Grodd time-traveling
that would be the craziest thing ever on
the TV show in son of ambush bug he goes
back and tries to kill them off but the
twist is this is kind of a silly story
and you even see the title of the comic
book here this actually looks exactly
like the flash of two world so it's a
nice easter egg for that the grog goes
back so far in history but he almost
ends up wiping out common ancestors of
both gorillas and humans so he's floor
did when he realizes that he can't kill
them without also killing himself it's a
very reverse flash type problem can't
get rid of Barry Allen without also
erasing his existence as the
reverse-flash number four during jla
generations number two he tried to run
central city and run for governor with a
mental control device that made
everybody liked him there are a couple
other things that he tried to do but
just a funny idea that garage going to
walk around and try and actually govern
human beings the thing is is
issue was actually written by John Oscar
and ER from The Suicide Squad comics so
nice deep cut for that number three
flashpoint Grodd from the comics
actually succeeded where main universe
garage did not he was able to take over
the entire continent of Africa but this
is during flashpoint so you have this
giant Amazon Atlantis war going on
everything's gone crazy the reverse
flashes run amok but while this is all
going on garad is actually doing very
well during this time line number two
new 52 flash met Grodd on accident when
the Speed Force shunted him into gorilla
City so he happened upon him and then
eventually that led to the sequence of
events whereby they had a version of
guerrilla warfare gorillas rushing in to
crush central city which is kind of the
threats that we're getting ready for in
this episode but the number one thing
this is really big hopefully there'll be
an easter egg for this on the TV show is
that he created zoom when he broke
hunter Solomon's back or directly led to
his creation we've already done zoom on
the TV show so maybe they'll have an
easter egg maybe some team member will
get maimed in a way that will cause them
to go evil in the future but we got the
new episode coming tomorrow I'll post my
video after it airs it's going to be
crazy there's also some new Wonder Woman
that I'm going to post you guys have
been asking me for an Aries video and
I'm thinking about making Monday's a
permanent spider-man bonus video day
like I do flash videos on Tuesdays all
the time let me know what you guys think
of that giveaway though there is a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'll
announce the winner when I post my flash
episode video while you wait for that to
post you can click here to learn all
about the vulture on spider-man
homecoming and you can click here to
learn all about the flash prophecy thank
you so much watching everyone looks like
5 i'll see you in the next video